so basically i have to stay in the car
because
of covid but i'm here to support blake
in case he wins
um i'm sorry gwen stefani
i couldn't hear you over that massive
diamond ring
i'm so full of love the 51 year old
singer gave her fans their first look at
her
massive engagement ring from blake
shelton on her insta story
sunday while she and her man were on
their way to the people's choice awards
so basically i have to stay in the car
because
a covet but i'm here to support blake in
case he wins
go cardinals yeah so gwen couldn't get
out of the car due to covid
but that wasn't gonna stop her from
showing up to support her man
i'm just sitting in the car waiting for
blake to win
hopefully and he's on the radio
do you hear that it's called god's
country and it's a good thing she came
along for the ride because the 44 year
old took home the award for country
artist
of 2020. we are back at blake shelton
just won a people's choice award
and naturally he gave his leading lady a
sweet little shout out
thank you to my new fiancee
gwen stefani
her name is gwen stefani uh
s-t-e-f-a-n-i
if you need to google it and figure out
who she is so
uh thanks for my uh inspiration and i
love you guys
thank you but back to that bling he's
like my bestie
fans caught a glimpse of her stunning
sparkler when she took off her mask for
a hot sack to talk
i'm here to support blake in case he
wins
yeah pause it right there you could see
that rock from a mile away well done
blake
well done thank you guys good night gwen
and blake got engaged
last month after five years of dating
somebody
that is let's see humble
kind down to earth selfless
talented on the top of their game
should i keep going i think i'm his
biggest fan
after blake popped the question they
both hit up instagram to share the sweet
news
blake posting this pic alongside the
caption gwen stefani thanks for saving
my 2020
and the rest of my life i love you i
heard a yes
i don't want to remember what i was like
before
gwen actually if that answers your
question and gwen
she wrote simply blake shelton yes
please
it's incredible to have um a best friend
like that guy
a source later told et that blake was
ready to take the next step
after spending so much time together
under quarantine amid the coronavirus
pandemic
quote blake has been the one who wanted
to take it slow in the beginning but
recently he decided it was time
during the pandemic they've had lots of
down time together and he truly saw the
importance of spending life with the
person you love
the source added that gwen quickly fell
head over heels for shelton and
knew he was the one during their first
year together